um I should say that that this is
actually a talk with the second half the
first half I got didn't realize it was
clustering and didn't and Gabe wrote a
slightly different talk however I in my
/ long response this morning I sort of
gave the substance of the last half I
thought so so let's proceed with with
this one okay so an outline just a lot
of this will have been covered by many
other speakers examples of our labels
networks and generative models non
parametric models which can be
identified with graph ons block models
which I will focus on with expected
average degree lambda not necessarily
the model but the graph as a whole and
asymptotics for three regimes one which
is actually in some sense the the easy
regime but also from a statisticians
point of view the most satisfying which
is when the degree goes to infinity
faster than the logarithm of n which
means in terms of erdos-renyi that there
are no isolated points and that's true
for all of these graphs then lambda
going to infinity but lambis goes Big O
of log in and finding lambda equals
bigger one which has been the domain of
many skilled prob lists with results
which gained from a statistician point
of view or not unfortunately
intrinsically or not that satisfactory
okay so here's an example if you've all
seen it this is a Facebook network for
Caltech 769 nodes average degree 43
which is pretty high you can't tell
anything from this but it looks pretty
let me switch quickly with mathematical
formulation
you see what I'm more comfortable with
but there will be some more pictures you
have so the graph as usual I'm talking
about an undirected graph so in other
words you you can't tell whether I like
you or you like me we both like each
other rather arbitrarily labeled
vertices a is he jason c matrix as usual
defines it and i'll also use just one
notation which I guess hasn't been
introduced which is di for the degree of
the I throat X and the implications of
course as a mathematical description
again I'm really I think preaching to
the converted about so I'll go very
quickly undirected means that relations
to a from are not distinguished
arbitrary labels means that individual
and geographical information is not used
but can be used for validation of course
following up on this morning's
conversation you really do want to use
the labels and and the validation
ideally comes from the outside as it
usually does in clustering clustering is
unsupervised learning right so there is
no real definition of cluster apart from
something that means something to
somebody in another field okay just
mentioning quickly some very elementary
descriptive statistics the degree of the
vertex the average degree of the graph
the number and size are connected
components the geodesic distance
homophily which which which measures
sort of the concentration of the graphic
just triangle means that if I like you
and and and and if a likes if a and B
are connected and B and C are connected
than a and C are and then there's a
large paper of leskovec language as dr.
Mahoney which has lots and lots of
different measures for large graphs
these the first four of course classical
ones now here's examples of networks
which I took from leskovec at all and I
which is basically you're plotting the
number of nodes versus a number of edges
and if you translate that in
i log scale and you translate that into
plotting degree versus number of nodes
what you find is that essentially the
degree grows in these cases as into some
small power however that could also mean
log n of course but in other words there
is some message here that n does grow I
mean that lambda the degree grows with
the with the with the number of notes
I'm sorry yes indeed thank you of course
okay stochastic models again we've heard
many of those this morning the earlier
any model which is probably the oldest
goes back to the late 50s and you could
it enables you to think about
probability distributions on graphs of n
vertices which is equivalent for
unlabeled graphs to thinking about
symmetric n by n matrices of zeros and
ones and aired or any slightly modified
place edges independently with
probability lambda over n where lambda
is the average degree sorry yeah and
choose to bruni trials so you have n
square trials and the probabilities land
over N and lambdas the expected average
degree the statistical generalization of
your any model which was again has been
mentioned before but let me remind you
is the natural one to induce
inhomogeneity if you want within these
exchangeable graphs so you have a
community label which you assume is a
multinomial there K possible communities
or clusters or blocks but we're talking
about population statistics and the
relation is that given the membership in
the communities the probability of an
edge is it depends only on the
membership of the two endpoints and the
edges are conditionally
dependent so k equals 1 is the elders
rennie model so this model again path
talked about and and as did peter now as
mentioned I'd like to go to a
nonparametric asymptotic model and
you'll see why I call it asymptotic I
mean that the model itself is asymptotic
so we have latent variables uniform 01
associated with vertices 1 through n you
have a function which is symmetric which
goes from the unit square 201 and you
have the graph probabilities are defined
by the probability of an edge given all
of the latent variables is depends again
only on the endpoints but is a function
H of cix EJ and that's what I like to
call a non parametric model now again
I'll mention again a property that the
Peter mentioned that a beautiful reason
if you want for considering these from
from a mathematical point of view is
that every probability which is on the
infinite graph which is invariant under
permutations of the labels is a mixture
of a certain piece of h's which are in
fact the ones that I defined so H is the
function which defines the probability
of an inch giving see I exceed right so
these P I these eight piece of acres are
all air gothic so let me just go back
remind you there is the piece of H so
just so this is really completely
analogous this again has been pointed
out before to the situation on the line
if you ask on the line you have
exchangeable random variables then the
Joint Distribution is always a mixture
of iid sequences and it's the iid
sequences which are actually our gotik
here these things are also a gothic
they're not quite I ID but they're
basically there's little knowledge of
what happens you know if you don't have
edges connecting you then then then you
have no information this also coincides
with the notion again that has been
mentioned this morning of the lavash
graph on I'm not going to use that
anymore but uh I'll just assume this
model which has been called the
exchangeable model from now on now as I
think Peter mentioned and also and also
pat there is a problem with just leaving
this function H fixed if you want to do
asymptotics because then you basically
automatically have expected degree of
order n which is never observed you
solve for example in the in the in the
examples I gave and many others and so
what you do is you you you scale it down
by a factor and a natural factor is the
probability of an edge that controls the
the the density of the graph and then
given that you have an edge you can tow
up by base theorem about the conditional
density of the two latent variables
given that you have an edge and that
function doesn't depend on it and that's
the function will play with the average
degree is Rho n times n minus 1 and that
prin abel's you to have the average
degree range from big 0 1 to Big O in
let's see morning thank you ok Oh
examples of models block models which
are where you have the H taking on a
finite number of values and these
correspond exactly to the block models I
believe we're defined by breathing
speakers you you essentially have class
or I define them you have classes and
then there's a probability of
communicating of having an edge but now
given
the membership of your class and so the
if you want the the latent variable
becomes discreet they're only you could
just as well say that you have a latent
variable which takes on the values 1
through k it's been noted early on that
block models do not have a desire the
property which has been noticed in
practice a lot which is that the degree
distribution tends to resemble a power
distribution and Chung and Lou and
others showed that of course by
modifying the this w sub n function
writing is a of you a OV times 1 over
Rho n which permits of course the a now
to be genuinely a density rather than a
probability you get whatever power or
behavior you want by taking a of you 1
minus you to the minus alpha and as a
model that I think most of you may have
encountered the so-called preferential
attachment model which has a nice
interpretation that nodes enter
sequentially and attaches to I and GN
with probability proportions a degree
and you can show that in a rather
precise sense is actually a pathetically
completely equivalent to drawing from a
graph with a equal to one month a
constant times 1 minus u to the minus a
half so it has the power law property
and ok alright i'll switch very quickly
and now i have worked on other measured
methods of estimating so now i'm going
to focus on on estimating parameters of
blocks of course identifying community
members and from a previous result by
you chin and myself we were able to do
something which computationally was only
marginally useful but i think from a
theoretical point is is moderately
useful interesting which is you can look
at the you can look at the data you can
look at the likelihood and ask how good
is the likelihood if you could compute
it in a reasonable amount of time in
classifying right you can write down the
lock you to the block models how good is
it in classifying individuals in each of
the classes and it turns out and I'm
I'll just jump over this it turns out
that be
cause of this oh and there's also
something called the variation of
likelihood which I think perhaps more of
your familiar with an eye on but this is
this is computable reasonably quickly
and the result which I'll quickly switch
to is that in this magic domain where
lambda sat n over log n tends to
infinity essentially you asymptotically
know the labels know all of the labels
right so it isn't that your error rate
goes to zero it's that you actually is
nailed down with probability tending to
one all the labels and because of that
you can easily conclude that indeed yes
in this regime maximum likelihood
behaves as it should as does variational
likelihood and they are the best methods
of classifying but anything actually in
this regime is the best left of
classifying because you're classifying
perfectly with with probability 22 10 k
lambda tank to infinity i will go over
very quickly because it'll be gone over
in greater detail by other speakers but
there are many methods as jim mentioned
spectral clustering pseudo likelihood
these are all methods which replied in
applications to block models and in all
these cases you can't as soon as lambda
goes to infinity more slowly than log in
you cannot nail everybody because there
are isolated points but you can drive
the mistake rate to zero this is
something I haven't dwelled on but a
statistician is one is somewhat
interesting parameters of these models
again when you know of course the
identity of the of the of the members
you can estimate perfectly I mean not
you can estimate the parameters of
optimal rates as if you knew the labels
which is that's well known here you
can't anymore and and I believe although
I don't think it's been shown that in
fact be aa below below landover log n
tending to to
infinity you cannot estimate the
parameters at the same rates as if you
knew the labels I am Nichols Big O one
has been a great deal of work actually
I'm i expect that Andreea will talk
about it nope okay but in any case
unfortunately the best you can hope to
do is this that is that the proportion
of mistakes is bigger than a half thank
you so okay yes ma'am that's correct
that's correct that's correct there are
theorems which I don't know if which can
be written down or say that if in fact
the data isn't generated from the block
model it's going to be look as if it
were generated from a block model which
is in some sense closest to your block
unfortunately the sense is in terms of
the cool bottle I blur metric in terms
of the infinite probability matrix the
lattice it but there it is and you can
okay this is something new which which I
wanted to talk about so I've been
working with a postdoc jointly of mine
and Mike's poorness our car and we asked
well okay so you have this block model
let's assume that it holds but we don't
know what K is is there a way of
choosing k in a more or less principled
way starting without knowing it and we
actually answered a somewhat simpler
question namely deciding whether k is
two or one in other words erdos-renyi or
two blocks but of course in principle
that can be used with any method of
clustering to choose when to stop right
because you start out by cutting once
and then you look at each of these guys
and then you decide whether to cut them
and what you get is after your
hierarchical method of clustering in
that way so
and we proved thanks to the work of
about 15 years of propolis that in fact
the you can take the eigen value of the
adjacency matrix minus its expectation
as estimated scaled as estimated and
show that it in fact it's a very trendy
model this goes to Tracy widom but if
it's not an airy-fairy model if it blows
up of course if there's more than one
block it blows up now it turns out
there's something amusing which which
which which was not quite expected which
I'll mention which is it actually Tracy
Witham in this case is not such a
wonderful approximation it's known that
for the gaussian for gaussian matrices
it's it's superb but in this case if you
actually look at it it isn't but what
can you do is you can do what's called
the parametric bootstrap you can take a
small number of observations right from
the postulated or any model with the
estimated p estimate the mean and
variance of the tracy witham
distribution under that plug it in and
you get much much better much better fit
it's a trick that was discovered a long
time ago by george box where he showed
that scaling high squirts actually did
better than high score in approximating
the Lord lucky ratio the two log line
okay all right so here's just some some
examples actually applied to data though
not real data but well real data yes but
no here is this is a case where I guess
leskovec mansion managed to get ground
truth by manually labeling people that's
I think I'll make and so so and he then
had a method of clustering of his own
which also involved which was dynamic in
which we didn't involve an explicit
stopping rule but but
and of course I'm showing this because
it turns out that we did much better
according to this average measure of
agreement with truth this is something
called the F measure which is precision
x recall x 2 divided by precision plus
recall and the white is the tracy witham
as corrected and the black is the less
quebec story and then just to give you a
moment of honesty we looked at this
famous karate club thing where in fact
truth is supposedly known at least
anecdotally that there is there was a
quarrel in the karate club and a certain
fraction of the members went one way and
another fracture the members went the
other way and so this is what's called
ground truth and if you use a very small
p-value on Tracy witham you get the
truth using spectral clustering entry
and at each stage and then as the p
value increases you cut off another
cleat now whether that's meaningful or
not we don't know we don't know much
more about the history the karate club
than that it's split so so that's the
story ok yes yes and you give a little
bit more details about your a certain
testing cake was one versus K goes to so
what do you ask you ah ok what's assumed
we really the test statistic is well
defined it's it's in that right ok and
so now the question is what's the null
distribution module that you apply the
test you reject for large values of that
test statistic and the null distribution
is aired as ready because that's what it
means to have one block one homogeneous
block and and and the alternative in
some sense
doesn't it suggests the form of the test
statistic but the test statistic isn't
tied to a particular alternative but but
your result I mean saying that you are
consistent for this test you need to
assume something on the alternatives
that there is a gap between the world oh
of course oh yeah yeah that's that's
right but did I say did I say consistent
I think when I said consistent it is
consistent yes with whose appropriate
conditions I guess I was more amused at
seeing that actually this method worked
in a more complex situation if you want
but yes it surely is if you have if you
have I think well if the eigen value the
eigen value tends to infinity if you
have a two-block model right so you have
you have consistency for any luck on
stone gap between the probabilities you
can come up with see if Rosa yes you can
well can you the trouble is that the
troubles of the probabilities of these
days are really nasty things they're
their sums over all possible
permutations and the labels but you're
quite right you could probably use the
variational you know the variational
likelihood for one block versus two
blocks is correct but whether that would
do better in a general situation where
in fact you don't believe there's a
block model but you're looking for
inhomogeneities that's less clear